parte se evalúa la segunda derivada de
ye gon respecto a x en el punto de la
curva donde x es igual a menos 1 y ya es
igual a 1 bien lo primero que vamos a
hacer es regresar al principio donde nos
dicen cuánto vale la derivada de con
respecto a x y eso lo tenemos acá arriba
observa dicen que la derivada de que con
respecto a x es igual hay que entre 3 y
cuadrada menos x así que vamos a notarlo
acá abajo para poderlo trabajar mucho
más fácil tengo esto de aquí y voy a
notar que la derivada de la derivada de
g
con respecto a x es lo mismo que bien
esto dividido entre 3 y cuadrada menos
ahora lo que nosotros queremos es la
segunda derivada de con respecto a x
ambas veces lo cual esencialmente es
tomarme la derivada con respecto a x de
ambos lados pero si aplicó la regla de
la derivada de un cociente aquí a mi
derecha esto parece que se va a volver
un poco peliaguda así que se me ocurre
ver si puedo simplificar este
procedimiento y para eso voy a trabajar
un poco con derivación implícita bueno
lo primero que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar de ambos lados de esta
igualdad por tres ya cuadrada menos x y
me va a quedar 3 cuadrada
- x
esto que multiplica a la derivada de con
respecto a x a la derivada de james con
respecto a x fueron va a ser igual a ye
y ahora tomaremos la derivada de todo
esto
así que aplicaré el operador derivada
con respecto a x de ambos lados déjame
notarlo el operador derivada con
respecto a x del lado izquierdo y el
operador derivada con respecto a x del
lado derecho y bueno del lado izquierdo
tengo el operador derivada con respecto
a x de todo esto así que observa que
vamos a tener que usar la regla de la
derivada del producto
primero tomaré la derivada de esto que
tengo aquí de tres ya cuadrada menos x
ya eso lo voy a multiplicar por la
derivada de ella con respecto a x ya eso
voy a sumarle la derivada con respecto a
x de esta derivada y voy a multiplicarlo
por el primero así que empecemos si me
tomo la derivada de tres y cuadrada
menos x
bueno eso va a ser lo mismo que primero
tengo la derivada de 3
y cuadrada con respecto a ayer lo cual
es seis veces y ya esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de yen con
respecto a x
si esto no te es familiar del cargo que
vayas a la sección de derivación
implícita en la calaca de min porque ahí
hay muchos vídeos realmente este tipo de
derivación es una extensión de la regla
de la cadena me tomo la derivada de tres
y cuadrada con respecto ayer que es 6
james ya esto lo multiplicó por la
derivada del ye con respecto a x que es
esto de aquí y ahora nos tomaremos la
derivada de menos x con respecto a x lo
cual es menos 1 muy bien y todo esto
todo esto lo vamos a multiplicar por el
segundo que es la derivada de james con
respecto a x muy bien y ahora a esto le
voy a sumar le voy a sumar la derivada
del segundo que me va a quedar la
derivada con respecto a x de la derivada
de ya con respecto a x bueno eso es la
segunda derivada del jem
con respecto a x ambas veces muy bien ya
eso habrá que multiplicarlo por el
primero entonces a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 3 y el cuadrado menos
bien al final solo estoy aplicando la
regla del producto una vez más tenemos
la derivada del primero por el segundo
más la derivada del segundo por el
primero por el primero y bueno esto va a
ser igual a la derivada de con respecto
a x lo cual es de james d
muy bien y ahora lo que nosotros
queremos es la segunda derivada de con
respecto a x ahora para obtener ésta lo
que podemos hacer es despejar la o
utilizar los valores que nos dan para
poder obtener así de una manera más
sencilla la segunda derivada de que con
respecto a x es decir si sustituyó estos
valores que me dan justo aquí me va a
quedar solamente una ecuación con una
pequeña cuenta de américa así que vamos
a hacerlo aquí dice que nos fijemos
cuando ya vale 1 cuando vale 1 entonces
lo voy a sustituir justo aquí lo voy a
sustituir por 1 y aquí también tengo
james entonces lo voy a sustituir por 1
muy bien y cuando x vale menos uno
cuando x vale menos uno aquí tengo x
entonces me va a quedar que en lugar de
éste tengo menos
cuidado con este signo menos uno bien y
ahora pensemos en cuánto vale la
derivada de con respecto a x cuando x
vale menos uno y llevarle uno bueno pues
me va a quedar que la derivada de james
con respecto a x esto es lo mismo que y
vale 1 entonces tengo un 1 entre 3 veces
uno al cuadrado lo cual es 3 - menos 1
menos -1 o sea que es lo mismo que bueno
un cuarto y tiene mucha lógica porque
justo fue lo que encontramos en el
primer ejercicio si recuerdas aquí
arriba en el primer ejercicio
encontramos que en el punto menos 11 la
derivada de ye con respecto a x valía un
cuarto muy bien regresemos a donde
estábamos a aquí y ahora vamos a
sustituir la derivada de y con respecto
a x por un cuarto así que en lugar de
esto voy a poner aquí un cuarto en lugar
de esto voy a poner aquí un cuarto y en
lugar de este de aquí voy a poner un
cuarto y observa que ya sustituye cada
uno de estos valores por valores
numéricos lo que va a ser muy fácil que
así obtenga la segunda derivada del ieh
con respecto a x vamos a ver primero
tengo 6 x 1
por un cuarto me va a quedar seis
cuartos o 1.564 menos uno bueno 64 menos
cuatro cuartos es lo mismo que dos
cuartos dos cuartos y esto lo voy a
multiplicar por un cuarto muy bien ya
esto le voy a sumar y aquí tengo la
segunda derivada de ayer con respecto a
x que multiplica a bueno 3 - menos 1 es
44 esto tiene que ser igual a un cuarto
de lujo
3 - menos 1 344 por la segunda derivada
de que con respecto a x eso tiene que
ser igual a un 4 y ahora tengo dos
cuartos por un cuarto bueno esto es lo
mismo que dos dieciseisavos y es lo
mismo que un octavo
un octavo más cuatro veces la segunda
derivada de james con respecto a x esto
tiene que ser igual a un cuarto muy bien
y ahora déjame bajar un poco la pantalla
si seguimos por acá abajo voy a obtener
que cuatro veces la segunda derivada de
james con respecto a x va a ser igual a
un cuarto un cuarto menos un octavo pero
un cuarto es lo mismo que dos octavos
entonces dos octavos menos un octavo es
lo mismo que uno
de lugo entonces cuatro veces la segunda
derivada de james con respecto a x es
igual a un octavo o dicho otra manera sí
/ de ambos lados entre 4 me va a quedar
que la segunda derivada de bien con
respecto a x cuando x vale menos 1 y ya
vale 1 es lo mismo que un octavo entre 4
lo cuales 132 sea y esta es mi respuesta
correcta ya con esto hemos acabado